doc how about diabetes it can be
reversed even in an old person like my
mom I don't care if you're 170 years old
if your heart is still pumping type 2
diabetes is reversible how do reverse it
well again she gets 290 essential
nutrients and she gets the secret sauce
which are two minerals they've been
proven and so you take the secret sauce
for the 90 essential nutrients and it
all goes away
this this was 1957 we knew this in the
animals we knew it for many years before
they but it was proven and then the
University of Vancouver up in Canada
repeated it in humans and said yeah it's
true it is back in the 60s now why don't
doctors do that why would they tell you
to take these nutrients which are God's
tools God stuff I call it they'd make 30
60 80 $100 for office calls when they
can treat you for 25 years or diabeetus
and then you go blind and you get your
feet cut off and have a heart disease
and all this kind of stuff as
complications of the disease and so
they've created a customer for life then
shoo didn't you have like a little
challenge from somebody said if you
don't do if this doesn't work I'm gonna
sue your so I'm always worse than that
he's he just try me destroy you yeah
this guy owns the third largest medical
laboratory in America his name is Jerry
Murphy he allows me to use his name he
had terrible diabetes and so we're
talking about diabetes he he had
terrible diabetes and here's a guy who's
connected with the top endocrinologist
the top doctors he's got his fingers on
the pulse of the cutting edge of
research when it comes to new drugs
coming alone for diabetes and he was
failing he's are getting tingling in his
feet he was gonna have to have his
lately he said well yeah we met in a
dark back room of a mom-and-pop
restaurant
kind of like it 5:00 in the morning so
nobody could see us right but he says
okay so why are we the dark room with
her is he gonna kill me the dark room he
says well because I don't want anybody
to see us together
I don't want me to give you any
credibility so that's fine well he says
well I'm gonna give you 90 days because
our mutual friend here rich says that um
you can get rid of my diabetes to 90
days I say I probably can I'll tell you
what I'll make you a wager wall okay
said okay I'm
for wagers he says if you can do it
we'll be best friends we'll do some
stuff together we'll help a lot of
people fair enough so what's the other
part of the wager he says I will destroy
you if you fail he said and he's helped
I said you're on Jerry and he says do
you better be sure because I'm keeping
my word I will destroy you Wallach if
you don't perform in three months time
all his numbers were normal for the
first time in his life Wow and now we're
best friends and he has a series of
clinics called well I'm going to tell
you another but he has a series of
clinics which only use our programs